Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, fünf Spieltage sind in der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer gespielt. Höchste Zeit, dass wir hier im Rasenfunk mal drauf schauen. Jetzt hier in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 178. Ach, es ist endlich wieder so weit. Zweite Liga im Rasenfunk. Mir hat es ja auch gefällt, liebe Leute. Gefehlt, liebe Leute da draußen, die mir alle geschrieben habt. Jetzt ist es wieder so weit. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass wir über die 2. Liga sprechen können. Ich habe mir dazu zwei Gäste eingeladen. Zum einen vom Millern-Ton. Ich muss euch nicht erzählen, dass das ein sehr empfehlenswerter St. Pauli-Podcast ist. Yannick Pohl, et Yannick Pohl, heißt er auch auf Twitter. Hallo, Yannick.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, du, ich bin schon an deinen Lippen geklebt vor dieser Saison. Du hast eine unglaubliche Saisonvorschau aufgestellt mit 18 Gästen zu 18 Vereinen. Es waren sogar mehr, denn ihr hattet ja zu St. Pauli dann logischerweise eine größere Runde. Aber das hat mir sehr viel Freude bereitet. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Und ich weiß ja, wie viel Stress sowas ist. Ich kenne das ja noch aus einem anderen Projekt. Also schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, also ich glaube, dieses Tor gegen Schalke, wo wir –ich glaube es war 1-0 –wo wir den Torhüter und die ganze Hintermannschaft gepresst haben und dann den Ball erobert und schnell das Tor erzielt haben, ist so exemplarisch für unser Spiel. Also jeder vom Stürmer fast bis zum Torhüter fängt an zu pressen und versucht, den Ball zu erobern. Also wir sind halt ein sehr eklicher Gegner. Und es kann sein, dass man sich dann spielerisch drauf einstellen kann auf uns, aber ich glaube, gegen so Powerpressing 60, 70 Minuten lang stellt sich es halt auch als gute Mannschaft schwer ein. Und das haben wir gestern überhaupt nicht geschafft. Ich glaube, wir hatten einfach zu viel Respekt von St. Pauli. Auch lessons learned, glaube ich. Zwei Wochen, um das abzustellen. Und ich hoffe, dass unser Spiel sich jetzt nicht großartig anpasst. Ehrlich gesagt, letztes Jahr war es grausig zuzusehen spielerisch. Und dieses Jahr kombinieren wir. Gibt es mal eine Doppelpassstafette. Seitenverlagerung funktioniert eigentlich. Also ich bin total zufrieden, wie es die ersten vier Spieltage gelaufen ist. So würde ich gerne durch die komplette Saison gehen. Habe ich kein Problem damit.
Das kommt jetzt überraschend.
Die Frage ist halt, ob wir es schaffen, das beizubehalten. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir unser Spielstil großartig anpassen. Wir versuchen ja eigentlich schon eben seit der Regionalliga-Saison. Da haben wir ein Spielkonzept entwickelt, das bis runter in die Jugend geht. Da war eben Ersac Zelimbegovic als Co-Trainer auch mit beteiligt. So versuchen wir eigentlich immer zu spielen. Und versuchen dann auch die Trainer und die Spieler dementsprechend zu traden. Und deswegen bin ich eigentlich zufrieden, wenn wir das irgendwie so die Saison durchziehen könnten.
Es gibt einen Fakt, der hinterlässt einen mit großer Verwunderung. In der letzten Saison war es so, wenn man sich die Tore nach Standard-Situationen anguckt, dass da eine Mannschaft auf Rang 18 in der zweiten Liga lag. Und zwar der Jahn aus Regensburg. 5 Tore nur nach Standard-Situationen erzielt. Und jetzt nach 5 Spieltagen in dieser Saison schon 6 Tore nach Standard-Situationen erzielt. Mit weitem Vorsprung Rang 1 in der 2. Bundesliga und ja auch die Hälfte der 12 erzierten Tore. Was hat sich da verändert? Kann man das festmachen an Personalien, an Freistoßvarianten, an Eckballvarianten? Gibt es da einen Unterschied, der erkennbar ist?
Ja, also anscheinend hat man sich da einen Spezialisten gekauft oder geliehen mit Sabrit Singh. Singh macht eigentlich jetzt fast alle Freistoße und Ecken oder Niklas Beste. Und Niklas Beste hat letzte Saison zwar auch ab und zu mal getreten, aber selten und anscheinend haben sie das jetzt einfach in der Vorbereitung öfters geübt, auch wenn mehr seit dem Doppelpass gesagt hat, wir haben es nicht mehr geübt. Und Christian Keller hat irgendwie gemeint, so viele Standards haben wir letztes Jahr noch nie geübt, seitdem er beim Jahn ist. Aber es hat halt einfach nicht funktioniert. Da waren die Schützen nicht da, da war das Selbstvertrauen nicht da. Und diese Saison klappt es halt dann einfach. Und wie gesagt, Singen hat echt ein feines Füßchen. Also wenn der ausfällt, haben wir dann wahrscheinlich wieder eine Schwäche in den Standards.
Okay, also dann können wir es an der Personalier festmachen. Ich glaube, da weinen so manche Fans von Vereinen, die das nicht hinbekommen, dass du sagst, ja, wir haben es halt einfach, es läuft halt jetzt einfach. Wir haben hier die richtigen Leute. Lass noch ganz kurz das größere Bild ausmachen vom SSV. Da wird ja jetzt nicht allen ein Begriff sein, wie da die Situation ist. Wenn ich mir mal die Finanzkennzahlen angucke, da haben wir natürlich die vom letzten Jahr schon vorliegen, 1920 die Saison, dann sehe ich, Jahn Regensburg führt die Tabelle aller Profivereine an. Und zwar in der Kategorie der Verbindlichkeiten. Der Jahn hat nämlich fast keine 1 Mio. Euro Verbindlichkeiten in der Saison 1920. Allerdings auch sehr geringe Bilanzsumme. Das Rohergebnis ist nicht allzu hoch. Und der Personalaufwand, also das, was man investieren kann in Gehälter für Mitarbeiterinnen und die Spieler, da ist man auf Rang 39 aller Bundesligisten der ersten und der zweiten Liga, also sehr weit hinten angesiedelt. Wie ist die Situation bei Regensburg? Wie ist die finanzielle Lage? Und wie stabil steht der Club da?
Also wir stehen, glaube ich, finanziell sehr stabil da, eben weil wir keine Verbindlichkeiten haben, weil wir in den letzten fünf Jahren brutal in unsere Infrastruktur investiert haben. Und das ist ja der Weg, den wir gehen mussten eigentlich. Also wenn man mal zurückschaut, bei der letzten Zweitligasaison konnten wir uns fast das Stadion nicht leisten. Es war eine Riesenherausforderung, die Stadionheizung zu installieren, also 2012, 2013. Da hatten wir überhaupt kein Geld, irgendwie in den Kader zu stecken, weil wir alles ins Stadion stecken mussten. Dann haben wir eben unser neues Schmuckstück bekommen, das die Stadt gebaut hat, und wir mieten uns da rein. Und dann sind wir abgestiegen in die Regionalliga. Das hat uns auch so ein bisschen geholfen, glaube ich, konsolidierungsmäßig. Aber natürlich mussten wir unbedingt aufsteigen. Das haben wir dann geschafft. Christian Keller ist halt auch ein guter BWLer. Wir haben ein sehr schlechtes Trainingsgelände gehabt. Das haben wir jetzt die letzten 5, 6 Jahre auf Vordermann gebracht. Dafür muss man natürlich Gewinne erzielen, wenn man es nicht mit Fremdkapital finanzieren möchte. Aber aufgrund unserer Historie, uns wurde schon mal der Strom abgeschaltet, kann man in Regensburg keine Taktik fahren, die auf Verschuldung oder auf Investition aus ist, weil das das Umfeld nicht hergibt und die Politik auch nicht. Das würde keiner mitmachen. Deswegen eben diese seriöse Wirtschaften. Wir versuchen so zwischen 5 und 6 Millionen Euro im Jahr Gewinn zu machen, um das in dieses Trainingsgelände zu stecken. Da haben wir jetzt wirklich ein sehr, sehr geiles Trainingsgelände für Jahnverhältnisse. Das nächste wird eine Jugendakademie sein. Das heißt, wir werden diesen Weg mit wenig Personalaufwand, viel Gewinne, um diese dann wieder zu reinvestieren, noch einige Jahre beim Jahn sehen. Deswegen, glaube ich, passt es auch bei den Spielern, die wissen, auf was sie sich einlassen, dass sie nicht reich werden, wenn sie beim Jahn spielen, dass es aber ein gutes Sprungbrett ist, dass die Stimmung hier gut ist. Das Gehaltsgefüge ist, glaube ich, noch nicht so wie bei anderen Vereinen. Jeder verdient in etwa das Gleiche. Natürlich wird es Ausreißer nach oben und nach unten geben, aber wenn die Leute sich in den Kabinen unterhalten, wird es keinen geben, der, weiß ich nicht, eineinhalb Millionen verdient, unter anderem nur 100.000. Also da kommt es auch nicht zu Neid. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen unser Erfolgskonzept. Aber unser Aufsichtsratvorsitzender hat dann gemeint, wir wollen uns in den Top 50 der deutschen Mannschaften etablieren. Und ich glaube, das haben wir eindrucksvoll geschafft.
Mensch, ein wunderbares Schlusswort. Ich könnte noch ganz lange mit euch beiden reden. Wir haben natürlich auch nicht alle Vereine jetzt ansprechen können, aber da werden wir noch weitere Ausgaben hier im Kurzbach machen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und wenn ihr enttäuscht seid, mag ich nur noch mal darauf hinweisen, es gibt ganz fantastische Vereinspodcasts unter rasenfunk.de/patrolkönntihr die hören und da könnt ihr euch zu den einzelnen Vereinen noch informieren. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Ich möchte euch verabschieden mit meiner absoluten, absoluten, absoluten Lieblingsstatistik nach fünf Spieltagen in dieser zweiten Bundesliga. Gewonnene Kopfballduelle, die Rangliste Werder Bremen ist letzter mit 15. Und wer hat die meisten Kopfballduelle pro Spiel gewonnen? Mögt ihr raten? Yannick, hast du eine Idee?
Naja, wenn wir jetzt eben die Verteidigung vom Jan schon angesprochen haben und auch gestern die die zahlreichen Ecken wurden alle irgendwie weggeschädelt, hätte ich jetzt gesagt, dass es auch da der Spitzenreiter ist.
Robert? Ja, würde ich auch sagen. Ich glaube auch Kennedy wird da ganz oben mit dabei sein.
Na, da liegt er leider beide daneben. Der Jan liegt da genau in der Mitte auf Rang 10. Platz 1 ist Heidenheim mit 32 gewonnenen Kopfballduellen pro Spiel. Es ist unfassbar. Heidenheim auch eine Standardmannschaft. Aber das wird sich noch so ein bisschen runter regeln, das ist mir schon klar jetzt im Verlauf der Saison. Aber 32 Kopfballduelle pro Spiel, das ist für mich zweite Liga. Das ist ja, so gehört es sich einfach. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Ich danke euch für eure Zeit. Zum einen, Yannick Pohl. Yannick Pohl heißt da auch auf Twitter. Vom Millan-Ton, der Millan-Ton, sehr ausführlich. Nicht nur zum FC St. Pauli, sondern auch durch die Gegnerbeobachtungen bekommt man da eigentlich auch einen ganz guten Gesamtüberblick über die Liga im Verlauf der Saison. Yannick, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du mal mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Ja, nochmal vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und ich möchte nicht vergessen zu erwähnen, was ich in der SSV-Segment getan habe, dass der SSV weiterhin Stadtmeister in Hamburg ist.
Ja, gut, dass du das nochmal geklärt hast. Jetzt haben sich die ganzen HSV-Fans, die zurecht fragen, warum wurde über den HSV nicht gesprochen, haben noch einen mitbekommen. Nun ja, so ist das. Und dann ganz herzlichen Dank an Robert Fischer. Als 1889 unterstrich.fm kann man dem Podcast folgen, bei dem er auch mit zu Gast ist. Auf Instagram ist er der robert-klp. Robert, danke dir, dass du uns in die Welt des SSV-Jahnen eingeführt hast.
Es war mir eine große Ehre, hier zu sein, dass der kleine Jan im großen Rasenfunk sein darf.
Also danke euch beiden und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie ihr das untertun könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de und ich bitte euch, tut das auch, denn wir wollen auch andere am Erfolg teilhaben lassen. Es gibt jetzt schon Gäste, Honorare und wir planen noch vieles mehr. In diesem Sinne vielen Dank für alle, die das schon tun. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!